[Music]
our production designer and his team
have done such a fantastic job of not
only creating cool environments but
sticking to this idea that I think is so
Central to their show of functionality
when I met Matt and Ben I felt like we
had a connection right away I was
attracted to this show for all of the
possibilities of where we had been and
where we were going to go in the
writer's room we're throwing things out
and we're like well what if there's the
surface level of the base but then
there's an underground level and what if
there's an asteroid hunting ship but
then there's also other types of ships
and Rovers and Seth was able to give us
like 95% of what we came up with which
is
insane let's just hope this doesn't get
to his head I'm surprised it still fits
in his
helmet both on the moon and even on Mars
shaves will not be Square they'll be
round or oval because of the difference
between inside pressure and outside
pressure one of the big things we keep
coming up against is that building a lot
of structures on the surface makes no
sense because of the radiation risk that
was a real exciting idea of like what
does that mean to go underground and how
do you make the world underground feel
different we use references from Naval
vessels you walk down a hallway do you
feel like you're in the bottom of a
battleship astronauts and cosmina
scientists and Pilots they all work
together but us down here at the end of
the day we are just the help the barrel
vaulted spaces like the a commissary or
the greenhouse are an incredible look
because it's translucent you can see
that there's orange light coming
in most beautiful thing I have ever
seen in the United States of course we
ended season 3 with everything getting
blown up Mission Control was destroyed
destroyed to the point that it needed to
be rebuilt within the same existing
shell so now it has a whole new look
it's got new consoles new lighting
everything's been redone the colors the
finishes today we embrace the 21st
century the beginning of a new
era we have a whole side of our story
that's in the Soviet Union I was
fortunate to be part of a scout to uh
two countries Bulgaria and Lithuania
where we were able to gather a lot of
research it highlighted for me the
differences stylistically that's so
different between here and there the
work we will do together will take us
far into the
cosmos I could never have done this
project without the support that I've
had the cinematographers the visual
effects people everybody it's an
incredible
[Music]
collaboration none of it would have been
possible without not all of
[Music]
you